a manhunt under way is under way for the
gunman responsible for an ambush-style
attack overnight on to Florida police
officers fellow miami-dade officers used
a pickup truck to rush their wounded
colleagues to the hospital bullet holes
could be seen in the car where the
plainclothes officers were sitting at
the time of the attack
now while Bojorquez is outside Jackson
Memorial Hospital trauma center in Miami
where the officers are being treated and
well good morning good morning as you
mentioned those officers were rushed to
this hospital in the back of a pickup
truck this is where they were dropped
off and with some help they were
actually able to walk through those
hospital doors the director of the
miami-dade Police Department says the
attack on his officers was unprovoked
this video shot from outside the
hospital shows a black Ford pickup truck
racing toward the emergency room with
the two injured miami-dade police
officers in the bed the undercover
officers who were operating as part of
the homicide task force's gang unit were
conducting surveillance inside an
unmarked car in a notoriously gang
ridden area when officials say they were
targeted the end result of that their
operation was that they were apparently
shot in an ambush-style
attack one of the miami-dade officers
was able to return fire but authorities
are not confident the suspected attacker
was hit it's certainly trying moments
for us all we got lucky tonight that the
officers will survive police have yet to
make any arrests but last night the
director of the Miami Dade Police
Department pleaded with the community
for help in identifying the shooter we
need you now to step up to the plate
these are the people that are causing
that havoc in our community and we're
not going to stop this isn't going to
deter us from doing our jobs this is
going to ignite a bigger fire within us
to protect our citizens
the officers injuries are not
life-threatening police say it's unclear
whether the suspects knew they were
targeting police either way they are
clearly dangerous and right now officers
are still searching the area where the
shooting happened
Charlie Manuel thanks